hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey got a sick cat so
Watson's joining us in the video today
or for views I'm really just agree like
that we're gonna watch the trailer for
Guillermo del Toro produced which means
he directed him in the circle of
everyone's eyes
antlers before we go into that I would
like to give a special thank you today's
video sponsored Ridge wallet oh yeah
that's right the ridge scared him you
scared you scared Watson he's just
terribly it's done under my level of
quality that you can expect from the
ridge people they make these nifty
minimalist metal plated wallets they
hold all your stuff in order to get that
money strap or a money clip fits
conveniently in a front pocket they also
got these nifty power banks weatherproof
backpacks with USB charging port built
in they make some awesome stuff phone
cases included so head on over to Ridge
comm slash reject nation to save
yourself ten percent and get some free
worldwide shipping get yourself a nice
minimalist wallet today we did not hit
under a minute you have pissed off
everybody hates the viewers only you did
not unless they buy original it
[Music]
that's beautiful
yeah I see there's the lift
you know dark in what cave of a small
town every day a little better ones at
school go home [ __ ] the one day leave
their people and make their baby their
[Music]
Big Buddha sick mr. black
[Music]
hey there just make some more in here
in here
agency had no food
[Music]
that's very unsettling oh yeah very
unsettling mm-hmm when to go yeah is
that what that's about weigh antlers are
often associated with Wendigo mythology
it's a Wendigo called it plot twist done
don't need to see it now that's right
that's why you come here folks you look
for accurate predictions whether or not
it's worth your time now it's not see a
fox searchlight you're going under the
can now that Disney owns you all right
you can actually spoil this yourself by
going online and reading the short
stories really easy really
yeah Nick antoshka who was the guy
behind channel zero and stuff he wrote a
short story and then co-wrote the script
that became this movie
what's hands stuff and stuff mm-hmm
you got a dick for in your head what a
dick for you got a dick for it yet
what's a dick for on my head I don't
know you put it there
what are you doing you've never heard
that no you've never done the dick for
all knows you got his deep monetize well
John would you think of it I think it's
a cool trailer I mean it definitely has
some Menace and Scott Cooper I think is
an interesting choice for a movie like
this because up until this point all I
know from him is pretty dramatic stuff
like crazy hard and out of the furnace
and that civil war movie with Christian
Bale this seems like a left turn into a
different genre and from a caliber
filmmaker like that I think that's what
gives me the most amount of hope this
kind of reminds me too of not the boy
with the mannequin boy but the other boy
that had Rainn Wilson it was about like
him and a kid and there's like something
up with the kid and I think there was
even an antler motif in that movie two
also got some vibes of like horns in
this I don't know I think it's got a lot
of Menace and mood at least as of this
trailer it looks horrifying and from
Nick and Tosca I have to imagine that
this isn't gonna be the kind
movie that cuts a trailer that looks
super intense and then nothing happens
until the very end I don't expect that
from this well yeah I mean it's got this
ominous tone about it kind of got it an
insidious build-up to it
when I say insidious I don't I mean the
word yeah which I learned three weeks
ago to this day
Odin in terms of legen as something
that's escalating it around the corners
it's probably not gonna be like slam bam
in your face type of terror the whole
time talking a little bit about the
garum of the Toro produced element of it
oftentimes when you know you slap his
name on similar with James Wan when you
slap their names on something the the
films are producing kind of looks like
one of their movies this doesn't look
like a Guillermo del Toro movie the
thing that does have some of a
sensibility at least looming throughout
it would be the fantasy element I
suppose of sort of this terrifying
folktale that is being brought into this
modernized small town story I am drawn
to that I like sort of the shadows of
the monsters that you see here I wonder
if like maybe in the finale of this
movie you'll get some really up-close
and personal looks on them I think Keri
Russell is very good in the horror genre
she's really proven that you know she's
won over overall versatile actress or
something I think she's really good and
you've seen little boy lead female white
character whose mom worked teachers look
like teacher teacher yeah I don't think
they're supposed to be related as at
least of the vague reading I did well he
still gets a little bit of babadook vibe
oh yeah yeah this seems to be the thing
of indie horror with a lot of them
usually these are the two kind of main
characters that you got here my mom kid
or movies yeah it's not mom kid directly
it might be that indirectly matronly a
figure and child figure really well put
matronly figure like mate relief figure
oh I like that borrows that you know
like a matronly thing and if there is a
wendi-go element to this I would be just
excited because that's not the kind of
mainstream horror creature we really
it's something you get when you're
watching like a supernatural and there's
enough episodes or something happening
where we can be like let's reach into
the
because if this becomes you know
something of a marketable you know hit
or whatever you know it'd be cool to see
a Wendigo story do that in a way though
I mean while this doesn't visually look
like a Guillermo del Toro movie it does
kind of remind me of some of his earlier
horror work before he had as many you
know big budgets to work with you know
stuff like Kronos character driven but
still kind of creature Menace kind of
comes out through this so I can see what
maybe drew him to this but John the big
question is is this some brand with
Disney you know I I think probably it is
it's definitely it's gonna be rated PG
I think studios X gotta worry man this
is not on-brand with what you purchased
clearly this was produced after the
acquisition occurred I actually heard
that some execs were audibly
uncomfortable during the screening of
this some of them were even like
uncomfortable nervous scared and you
know that's not what you want when
you're watching a horror movie
especially notable you want for yeah you
want families to be able to come to this
firm
they were they were very much misled
also Todd so he's always gonna be known
as Jesse Plemons Plemons who is laying
the brother improvements ever be a
wonderful wonderful actor I can see
being like a Richard Jenkins you know or
you're like you're the main go to
supporting guy for projects in every
character yeah exactly I don't know if
he'll be like the a-list lead I would
like him to graduate to there be cool if
he broke that mold cuz he is he does
have such rain it's to the point where
what I see him in a trailer I get
excited that he's in it cuz he know he's
gonna bring something to it even though
he's barely in it he looks like he's
probably gonna die at least by the
synopsis I read he ought to have a
decent role because I think the film I
think Keri Russell is his sister and
they're kind of the central figures or
something and with the little boy I mean
you gotta get we ever talked about him
at all oftentimes creepy little kid is
just creepy little kid and while this
movie does look creepy the vibe that the
child is bringing to at least this
teaser trailer does seem more emotional
based that seems that's where the roots
are in and not just let me tell you a
creepy story in class it doesn't sound
like oh what's wrong with this kid it
sounds more like what's this kid bin
yeah yeah and I appreciate that
distinction all right well this looks
cool man Guillermo del Toro keep
directing and writing films like this I
hope Lord and Miller continue to make
awesome into the spider-verse movies
editing rate job directing that when Tim
Burton did Nightmare Before Christmas oh
yeah I can't wait till he directs the
sequel his vision is original is yeah
yeah thank you for being here you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification Bell thank you
so much to Ridge Wallet for sponsoring
this video that link I would like to
give a patron the day shout out to a new
patron named Chris wah Moff I mean
getting know this gentleman recently he
is from Kamikaze Michigan Kelly Kelly
Kelly lalalala mo Kalamazoo Michigan hey
there you go Kalamazoo Michigan
fourth time's the charm matriarchy in
heritage what did you say he's in
watching our channel for quite some time
now a homeboy actually works in mental
health which I very much am proud to
know him for I love mental health I love
mental health too I was telling him like
I've been in therapy for many years I
actively listen to personal development
to better train my mind I take a lot of
psychedelics
I also abuse adderall so yeah you're my
kind of do solutions and I found out
that when him and his his friends played
basketball he said that we are usually
what's going on in the background oh
nothing like listening to a reaction
yeah wow thank you so much for being
here you gave me this like giant
breakdown of the crazy kind of work that
you have to deal with I'll say I feel
like it'd be way too personal it's going
to the amount of work that you actually
do than seer thank you to the
contribution that you've been making for
what I believe has been like at least a
couple of decades at this point if you
are someone who is having some kind of
mental health or emotional struggle
don't be afraid to seek help
drugs regenerate